[Music]
[Applause]
tonight comes to us via Winnipeg Canada
please welcome the absolutely hilarious
I shall [ __ ] come on everybody
yes oh my goodness you guys thank you so
much for being here this is so awesome
oh I'm so so so excited to be here
I had a baby recently yeah thank you
don't worry he's on here I left him in
the car it's fine I rolled the window
down and gave him a gun so he's fine
Mercedes like I I don't know about
anybody else but I spent my whole life
trying not to have kids because that's
what they teach you as a young woman
isn't that anybody else just like pull
and pray and pray some all right like
just that's like all my whole life
that's what I spent my time like that's
what's been in my brain and then I got
married we decided we were gonna have
kids and it just it stuck my old habits
stuck and my husband came home one day
and I was just like bawling like at home
I was late I was crying I was like snot
was coming out and he's like baby what's
wrong I was like he's like okay but like
we were trying right okay we can do this
you know
hung up a call with Planned Parenthood
and when he looked away I just quickly
spit out the plan b pill but we're happy
we're happy it's wonderful I'm very
delighted we had to take some pregnancy
tests to confirm what we suspected
anybody taking pregnancy tests shame
yourselves um it's like I thought there
was gonna be a lot of science involved
with a pregnancy test you understand
like someone's cackling cuz they
understand it's you just you go to the
drugstore and you buy a magical pee-pee
stick like that's
there's no Bunsen burner there's nope
you don't have to wear goggles nothing
just like you pee on a stick I was like
this is this is it we went home I peed
on it a line shows up and I was like now
what like wait two minutes of another
line shows up life's over
that's it and then the lines came but
they were very very faint so we were
kind of like maybe no no and so I was
like okay I don't know what to do here
we took two of those they both were like
faint so my husband went out to the
drugstore again and he bought two more
did you know that you can get ones that
just say yes or no why are we wasting
our time with these other ones I want
one that says like [ __ ] you with child
that's all I want to know for sure we
took two more and they both said no so
why me I probably should have done more
investigation but instead I drank a
bottle of Merlot okay her son's fine
it's a third eye but he's fine he's like
an iPhone 11 you know he just sees in
virtual reality um no it's uh it's it's
interesting I I am married though I'm
married to a white man
it's a weird reaction right that's for
sure white person that's sharing
whatever I say that like it's always
like something like oh good for you you
got and I'm like that's so weird it's a
weird like encouraging racism do you I
mean where it feels like they're
encouraging me for getting into a good
college it's just it's too much and
that's always why people cuz black
people have a very different reaction
I'm like I'm married to a white man
they're like are you okay link twice if
you need us to call nine-one-one they're
all trying to take like flash
photography with my face to make sure
it's not like a get out situation it's
very scary
um I don't say that cuz it matter like I
say that because if I don't say that
he's a white man then everyone will
assume I'm married to a black man and if
I'm standing next to any black man after
the show he'll be like your husband he's
so cute I'm like this man is 75 years
old and it's my dad
it's weird because like I mean I grew up
in an area in Canada where the area I
lived in didn't have a lot of diversity
like there was just like a lot of like
Ukrainian immigrants and then me and
like there was one eligible black
bachelor for all of the women in our
area one just one and it was my brother
so you would not date me I tried I asked
him what a lot um
did not want me know I do I come from a
mixed family um so my my mom is white my
dad is black but not just like regular
like my mom's my mom's like the whitest
white lady you've ever seen in your life
dude I'm talking like you know like the
white people where you can see like the
blood going through the veins in my
mom's one stage whiter where you can
just see her organs functioning see when
she was pregnant me she did not have to
take anything off when she went to the
doctor she just lifted her shirt and I
was in there like everything's cool it
was great though growing up with a white
mom because she never spanked us which
was delightful and it wasn't like it's
not what you think it's not because she
was progressive or anything um she just
didn't want to seem racist you
understand you cannot be the whitest
lady in the world with too little brown
kids in public like oh no people will
walk out of places like Save the
Children hmm it was a great time
my brother and I realized she wasn't
gonna hit us in public we were just
little [ __ ] walk around like kicking
other kids stealing candy like what you
gonna do Michelle but she was like she
caught on to she's like haha I'm gonna
beat you at home we would just walk to
the nearest white person we could find
like pull their coat Elpis this white
lady stole us from our heart
we are scared I'm cold
it's time but my mom is the white as my
dad as the blackest man I've ever met in
my entire life like just like you see my
family and everything oh my god that's
so beautiful a ghost in a shadow made
love that's beautiful I'm a special
right there
like all of our family photos like this
is the racism that I experienced all of
our family photos somebody's really lit
do you understand how hard that is like
I went home a couple of weeks ago and I
saw all of our family photos and
everyone looks amazing except for my dad
is just like eyes and teeth in the
background like just one year they got
it right though you could see my proud
father standing there but like my mom
look like an apparition just wandered in
it's tough my dad is a black man okay he
is very like when I when I was like a
kid my dad was finishing his school like
his PhD and so he wasn't around for some
bits of time and I had some friends who
had never ever met my father so when he
finally came home my friends were like
oh my god you have a black dad oh my god
you have a black dad
the true what they think was like what
are you asking me if my dad has big dick
that's a weird question I don't know how
to answer I mean look at him look how
dark he is of course he does are you
kidding me
it's a huge you guys is huge we step
play jump rope with it on the weekends
okay real big
double dutch if he was excited I'm
telling it was big it was a big one okay
real big uh I think it's amazing I'm
like my parents like they did suffer a
lot of racism my mom grew up in a small
farming community in Canada with a
hundred ninety people she went to the
big city and she met my father who was a
man who had just come from Nigeria and
at 19 my mom met my father and six
months later they got married and they
are still married to this day is that
amazing phenomenal so I was like I want
to know what this love story is I was
like mama tell me what the story is how
did you guys meet she's like okay well
assisted beautiful story um I was at
university I didn't know anybody so I
went down to the gymnasium by myself to
practice badminton I was like what so
yeah I was like so you went down to the
gym is you got a racket you set up a net
you got a bird of you to hit it over
then what you just run around like good
shot Michelle like pick it up every time
what's wrong that's a good cry for help
more than anything else jack none and
then your father walked up and he was
wearing short shorts and long socks made
a big girthy mustache and we played
badminton and the next day we met at the
quad and then you know the rest is
history I was like that's beautiful and
then a couple weeks ago I was home she's
like you know I had a couple glasses
bottles of wine and she goes oh sorry
like yes I do Michelle yes I do okay so
I was you know University I went down to
the gymnasium to play bat and seemed by
myself I'm like really we're not
changing this part of the story
we're you have a chance to change
history we're keeping it okay that's on
you now that's on you uh Sigma and your
dad you came up we played and the next
day we were gonna meet at quad but we
didn't have cell phones into the
Facebook's and all these things I
couldn't you know take a picture of him
so I went to the quad but I really
remember what he looked like black man
before I went there and I saw a
good-looking black man so I took his
hand in a way I went and I was like whoa
that's horrible like don't ever tell Dad
that story and he poked his head he's
like he's okay I was from Nigeria I had
never met that white woman this one took
my hand I went with her you know I was
like I think there's still a white woman
and a black man back in the day who
think that they were supposed to my
parents and think they got stood up and
I got stuck with these racist idiots
instead it's amazing
my parents married they went to Nigeria
they had my brother they had me I was
born in Nigeria and then I moved to
Canada and my name I see is very very
popular name in Nigeria in America
everyone gets it wrong i Herman's like
oh hello Ayesha hello Alisha
one time someone just introduced me like
everybody welcome to the stage and he
just forgot my name so he was like yeah
Shaniqua whatever and I get offended I'm
like I tell people how to say my name
properly all the time I'm like I shot
like an eyeball and shop like remember
that it's easy my friends were like why
don't you just go buy your full first
name if it's an issue for you and here's
the issue for me is that my full first
name is Aishah with a tu at the end okay
so on paper it reads I should too oh
that's cute whereas I show on Oh
the problem is that the correct
pronunciation of my full first name is I
shat I shat that's my legal name do you
understand how hard that is I'm like
what happened my mom pushed for 36 hours
and she's like yeah that sounds about
right
it's a [ __ ] do you understand how hard
it is for your name to be I shat like
what's your name sir Bob hi Bob I said
like no one no one's raising their hand
just shake your they're just looking at
you like we're you know like it's not
cute
but I was dating a guy while ago who is
like you know what that's your name
those are your people that's your
ancestry you got to go by that you got
to feel that I was like you know that's
true I shouldn't be ashamed of this is a
beautiful African Arabic name so I
started walking around like yeah i shat
deal with it people like that's what
like I was I had to go through the
border from Canada all the time to come
here do understand how hard it is going
through borders and being like what's
your legal name yeah you know I'll just
stay in Canada I'm fine everything's
good going to Starbucks like Frappuccino
four oh god no I'm like yes you say it
barista [ __ ] like I started to
feel empowered about my name like I shat
i shat I [ __ ] yeah feels good until the
first time he and I had sex that guy cuz
it's a very awkward moment when you're
in the throes of passion with somebody
and you look back and he looks up with
his beautiful eyes and says it feels so
good I [ __ ] like what do you say back
you know I was just like yeah me too
okay I do that joke and I'm not sure
what position were in you're gonna mean
like
he's going forward I'm jumping up and
down there's got to be a third person
involved right it's not a two-person job
right there man yeah it's it's tough so
I moved from Nigeria and moved to Canada
and then I moved to America because I
love struggles so much so delightful and
everyone I moved you from Canada they
were like oh my gosh America's still
racist I was like I know everyone else
right it's fine but like Canada is also
racist as well it's just like a
different kind of racism it's like
passive-aggressive right like I like if
I was gonna personify racism in Canada
it's like you're your frenemy you go
over you're like oh my god I just bought
these jeans like it's my butt look big a
member and racism Canada is like beauty
standards are hard I wish I could gain
weight like you Oh like just hope you
walk away being like I don't know is
that good is that bad like what's
happening but racism personified in
America is just different like you're
walking down the street feeling good and
your favorite pair of jeans and someone
you didn't ask anybody anything someone
just walks out on the porch and goes
yeah you're like okay I know where we
stand
good good good I know what's going on
but I'll tell you something amazing that
happened to me when I moved from Canada
to America I had a real revelation so in
Canada I would describe myself like we
don't like to put people in boxes in
Canada like no one wants to like make
you just one thing right like if they
would ask me who I was and what I was
about my background and stuff I would
tell them like I'm I'm a mixed I'm a
bi-racial woman I'm part Nigerian and
part French and part English one time I
lived in Korea for a while their ever
there like writing it all down on the
census yeah you go girl you everywhere
like you got it you got it
oh you know like no one wants to put you
in a box and then I arrived in America
and I was like yeah I'm here I'm here
hey man Bob I'm a bi-racial mix with the
baby girl you black okay
pick a team baby girl pick a team get
with your people over there okay like I
became black when I came to America this
is amazing
do you understand how a me like
obviously there's lots of bad things
that go along with being a black person
in America but there are also a couple
good things let me tell you what as soon
as you become part of team black you get
a signed picture from Michelle and
Barack did you know that just in the
mail just I don't know I didn't tell
them my address I just knew every year
on my birthday
Oprah sends me a new car okay this is
just my favorite one black don't crack
okay so I'm 73 I'm like if I'm gonna get
arrested at a higher rate than any other
race in the whole country then I want to
look good my mug shots okay I'm being on
Team Black is one of the best black
people make the world better can I just
say that yes white people if you're not
clapping oh you better get your hands up
okay it's true if you ever have a chance
to join Team black do it white people
you do not have that chance do not try
we make the real better we you everybody
wants to take from us from our music
from our hairstyles like everything are
our art our dancing like if you walk out
of here tonight and there's just some
like old homeless black men who put a
shoe on his head in two weeks time the
gap is gonna have a sale on a shoe hats
because they're all the rage that's just
the way it works okay it's amazing um so
now I live in LA and it's a trip in it I
came from Canada and everyone's like oh
my god la oh my god that's where
everyone makes it that's where everyone
gets rich or else just marry Sony who is
rich it's gonna be amazing you're gonna
find a rich guy and you're gonna get
married to him and I was like I don't
want that I've never understood the
whole like marry a rich man because
being rich doesn't make you kind or give
you a bigger dick like
that's all I want in life is to find a
kind-hearted big-dicked man okay just a
big swinger of a dick girthy real give
me lots of foreskin give me a five skin
okay give me my wine forget the money
we'll live on his dick okay but III
didn't girls I had a friend who's
secretly rich I didn't even I didn't
know that I didn't know he's rich and I
went to his place when I came down and
he had a condo that overlooked the beach
in Venice that was multiple stories and
I was like oh my god I finally get it
you know like I've been giving BJ's in
basement apartments you're telling me I
could be balls deep while waving at a
sailboat a location location location
you know what I'm saying oh my god I'm
like the guy I dated before I moved to
LA lives in a basement apartment with
shag carpets one time I was doing my
duties on my knees and like a cockroach
just walked past his head you're like
okay like just
[Applause]
reevaluate it stuff
I like sex anybody else yeah yeah I
specifically I like orgasms okay
like I think everybody I think everybody
should be more enthusiastic about orgasm
think we should he'll have like an O J
and a no every morning prescribed by a
doctor like that's what I think
and it's different like for men and
women it's just a little bit different I
think orgasms you know I'm saying like
he's having one right now it's just
different like for guys I get it
you know you're all different I guess in
the way you have orgasms but generally
you're pretty much the same you're like
a bunch of racehorses all just waiting
to get out wearing different colored
bibs okay you're individuals but like as
soon as they raise that bar like that's
the only guy like just going for gold
you know sure there's like maybe one
horse who's like my my turn in this way
what's going on when old horse in the
back was collapsing like this happens to
a lot of horses
[Music]
[Laughter]
I think that that entities need to put
more effort in for women to have good
orgasms and I'm not talking about like
more effort in the bedroom I need more
effort like in general to make women
feel special and heard and loved you
know like she's not and she got sent I
don't as women we want we want you to
like take us out somewhere right like
give us food we're hungry very hungry at
all times when you bring us back home
like give us some wine
give us some candles lit put on some
nice music give us a sense to a massage
so that we can start to you know loosen
up and get in the mood and and start to
imagine that we are with someone else I
[Laughter]
don't want to be with you but I think
that what it is is really I think that
men need to be more understanding and
like here women more when it comes to
like sexual things like oral sex like I
think there's too many guys who are
cocky about oral sex am i right ladies
yes you said that very quickly before
I'd even said oral sex MRI leash yeah
okay thing assists at PSA right now
let's go like there's every time I say
like guys will be I'm good at it I'm
like nope you yelling like that means
you're not okay just what um and like we
get it right like women we understand we
all were all different we want different
things people like you're all a
different flower you know what no that's
[ __ ] okay it's not a flower it's not
a two-up it's a vagina get real okay
I'm not fooling your home like come sell
my [ __ ] like no I know what I have it's
wonderful it's beautiful but I want you
to understand mine it's different than
your last girlfriends okay it's very
different like women we the only reason
women do yoga is so we can get the
positions to help you out
we want you to succeed when you go
downtown okay we will just like you know
need mean like one time I just told the
guy lay there with your mouth open I'm
gonna run over top you a couple times we
will do all the work we will do all the
work when we women and then we'll just
give you credit because that's what
women do we don't care we just want to
get to that orgasm and I had this one
guy who he was going down I mean we're
dating and he's like I'm really good at
it let me just show you what I got it's
like I already I know you're not gonna
do it but be able to try and he went
down and he was you know doing his thing
and it wasn't quite feeling right I was
trying to give him the old like
suggestion Samba you know I mean and it
was he stopped me in the middle of
everything anyway uh I got this
no you don't okay if I have to stop you
it means you don't got it okay and I
think I understand because guys have
fragile egos and you can't just be like
I want this because they want to be they
want to be imagine if they want to come
up with something by themselves so I
think we just have to talk to them in a
way that massages there you go in a way
that they can understand and a lot of
guys I've dated like sports so I think
we just need to talk to them like it's a
sporting event right like he's going
down and he's doing a good job then you
just start doing the wave you just do
the wave you can you can keep doing it
like just let them know get them to sign
your jersey afterward you know and if
they're not doing it quite right you
just let them know like it's a sporting
event again you're like okay no
like just get everyone chanting his name
I think that's fair I think that's very
fair um yeah I don't know I don't think
it's a big deal uh I think every every
woman should have a sex toy everybody
ever like this old guys like yeah I
think every woman should have a sex toy
is everybody is every woman have a sex
toy if not I've got a box in the back I
will bring them out throw them into the
yacht if you get a sex toy you got a sex
I I think every woman should have a sex
toy and I think if any man has a sex toy
you are a psychopath I accidentally
walked down the aisle of men's sex toys
at the sex shop the other nine has
anyone done that Oh with Halloween down
there my friends like for us we have my
favorite vibrator is a purple beaver
with its tongue sticking out mmm very
Canadian of me that's beautiful I went
on the men's 612 G I was walking down
like just horror show after Horror Show
there was just one sec start that was
just a but this a but suctioned to a
counter I'm like what it had a name it
was called Linda that's great like I'm
like if I wanted to be out in public and
discreetly go pleasure myself I've got a
small toy I stick at my pocket I go to
the bathroom you excuse me ma you know
you come back everyone's fine what a
guy's dude just bring like a tote bag
with them I just got some me time to
take care of over here like what is
wrong with you people I was talking
about sex toys one time on stage and
this guy stood up from the audience and
interrupted my whole set and he just
wagged his finger he went no no no no if
you go home with me you don't need a
vibrator it's like really dude
unless you're only moving the bedroom
you know for like three hours then I
also need the sex toy it's a lot but now
I'm married I'm married to a wonderful
wonderful man he he proposed to me just
like he wrote me a wonderful note and
and got on a knee and he gave me this
ring and it was a beautiful really
beautiful moment cuz I was like oh my
god I thought if I'm a Bachelorette like
I've been a Bachelorette my entire life
and then one day someone got on their
knee gave me an expensive piece of
jewellery and was like I want to commit
my life to you and I was like awesome
but first let me see some strange dick
first yeah what like what is wrong with
me
I went to Vegas for my bachelorette
party oh yeah I told people they were
like Oh what happens in Vegas stays in
Vegas have you guys been to Vegas it's
horrible
is it it's like like if you're going to
Vegas and you want to look at women
women women want delish we all go to
Vegas I'm like oh my god I'm gonna wear
the [ __ ] they have everyone I've
drawn it at my areola show but I don't
care it's Vegas but though like women
look amazing in Vegas guys every guy
there's just a 20-year old douchebag
from Minnesota that's Pat on backwards
drinking slush vodka out of a plastic
guitar if that's what happens in Vegas
it can stay in dance I went there
because I wanted to see the Thunder from
Down Under with my girls yes
one person has gone everybody should go
if you haven't if you haven't been to
the Thunder from Down Under
it is um it's a male revue and it's not
just tripperz it's a lot more than that
okay
way more meaningful there's like
choreography
there's costume changes there's
pyrotechnics they like the boobs on fire
it was amazing we went a group of ladies
and it was one of the most uniting
experiences I've ever been to in my life
like a whole theater 400 women different
walks of life different ages different
backgrounds and we all became one one
horny monster as soon as I turn those
lights down everyone's like yeah show us
ball-like just terrifying you know and
they start the show off for like ladies
the Thunder from Down Under is owned and
operated by women if I'm gonna objectify
a man I want it to be on a one-time oh
it's it's a magical a magical place and
magical time I'll tell you that right
now all the men who are in there like
there's just something special about
them one guy like couldn't do their
choreography because yet his eyes were
crossed but he had an extra AB so what
kind of worked out you know ii mean like
but like every guy was in there we were
all cheering for them and it was like
guys we would never look at on the
street do any mean like just like the
guy was the most popular for our group
at least he was 4 foot 11 and he had a
long ponytail and a long beard and he
had shaved his ass and grown like the
ingrown hair pimples but he just oiled
over it he's like they don't love it I'm
like personally I was just churning cuz
his confidence I thought that was
amazing to just come out there and they
came out and it was like they all did
the same sort thing like walked on stage
and they just rip off and take half the
clothes off and they ended up just dudes
in like Doc Martens and socks be like oh
oh then they'd walks one side of stage
like yeah
oh and then they venture that's how to
be like oh no I don't I don't know we
like it too I guess I don't know then
there'd always be one table was one girl
was like okay yeah
you'd walk over him like yeah yeah and
they all have this same finishing move
in walk over be like yeah a grinding
grinding grinding grab her head and dick
punch every single time like just like
women walking out with two black guys
like that lets a great show it was a lot
and like my girlfriends were like you've
got to cheer if you want them to come
over it's like I don't want them to come
over
stay away but then midway through the
whole thing they stopped the show and
they said now we've got a special event
we're gonna do it's a contest we need
three lucky ladies to come up from the
audience on stage and I was like stage
time let's go I'm in you know you're
like okay we're gonna have you guys give
us your best five-second fake orgasm now
it's like I don't think that you needed
to specify fake
like was there really anyone in the back
like I'm gonna do I'm gonna do it they
said no pictures but what about coming
does anybody know who like no one no one
no one was that horny we were all like
uh why do we pay money for this but I
went on stage and I was like well now
I'm gonna win cuz I'm competitive so
let's go and for the first few seconds I
was like oh yeah give mama what you like
oh yeah and then I just turned to a bag
of garbage I was like yeah yeah I start
like sprinkling it into the audience
there's all middle-aged ladies and
they're like all that to say I want a
Thunder from Down Under hat you guys
yeah did I put on my husband's head when
I came home 100% it's amazing he is he's
a wonderful wonderful man my husband
he's delightful um here's something
though I'd never really been in a really
great long-term relationship like this
before and when I got with him he
suggested we take a shower together such
a thing anybody else says no don't do it
stop it stop doing that stop making it
seem like it's a normal thing it's not
you can't here's the thing I go into the
shower to clean myself
it's not a cure I'm like all right like
I'm like doing all the nooks and
crannies plucking and all like that's
not what I want anyone does that's not
my best side you don't I mean like I'm
in with him we're still new I'm still
trying to look sexy for him so I'm like
yeah the shark has two pities - yeah
what do I wash that is sexy okay
think I should think oh yeah oh oh oh
baby oh oh I gotta watch my boobies this
was dirty
[Music]
well I was dipping him in mud early I
gotta get him clean for your baby just
20 minutes of tip washing then we leave
the shower and I'm like just disgusting
and dirty everywhere else but just shiny
clean a real circles here I'm a woman a
black woman with natural hair so that's
not an easy shot you can't wash your
hair in the shower with a man in there
am i right are there any ladies here
with natural hair you know I'm talking
about because if you're gonna comb
through your hair in the shower you're
gonna have a lot of hair come out it's
like a puppy dog that you've got at the
end you cannot shower with your poodle
and your man you get to choose one of
the other right and I'm like I was in
there showering away one day just like
calming and having a good time singing
some Lizza
you know my husband came home early from
work and he jumped in the showers like
surprised I was like oh my god I just
threw the puppy and I was like whoa hope
that landed some where's the head baby
you know what I'm doing you know what
I'm doing just and everything was going
fine until he let me get your back and I
turned around
the puppy had landed on my ass right
there
I'm just spidering its way down my leg
and shower and he was like oh my god
what is that nothing going on I'm so
embarrassed
um that's my hair that's what happens
when you're not here I comb my hair and
it falls out it was like oh whew because
I thought you'd [ __ ] yourself but he
stayed in the shower that's why I knew I
loved him there's something people don't
tell you that things change when you get
married you're I'm saying I never been
silent you're all married people it's
it's a real shift when you're married if
you're saying I'm happily married he's a
wonderful guy he's like a sexy man he's
got a heart of gold you know for arms
he's very you know he's a wonderful man
um but before I was with him I used to
have a lot of sex dreams anybody else
have a lot of dreams like I would I
would go to sleep and I would dream
about somebody maybe like I don't know
mostly Idris Elba mixed with Daniel
Craig anybody like not mixed like they
didn't make one person it was like the
two of them just joined at the hip like
there was like four hands and two dicks
you know getting it from both sides just
um and I used to like I'm a great
sleeper because I would go to sleep and
I just like wake up having an orgasm
like that would happen to me on the
regular and it was delicious
okay and then um I got married and
here's the thing I'm committed to him
I'm like with him you don't I mean and
iíve said vows you know till death do us
part I said nothing about sleep in those
vows that is Mama's time okay like I did
good night baby no come here
Idris Elba Craig like I'm like just go I
didn't feel bad about it either but um
we've been married for just over a year
now and over time my sex dreams have
changed and now all of my sex dreams
or about my husband you understand how
unfair that is I have sex with him all
the time in real life I want something
different at night okay I want something
else I want like you know variety is the
spice of life and like he's wonderful I
love having sex with him but like that's
not what I signed up for okay and it's
like it's it's been challenging it's
been really challenging um but last week
I'm proud to say that I finally had a
sex dream about somebody who was not my
husband
thank you it was the cashier at Ralph's
all his acne was there as well so and we
were we were having a great time we were
having a great time and then in that
dream my husband showed up in the drink
just ruined everything right he was like
what are you doing I was like oh my god
I forgot I was married like I like
freaked out in the dream and I woke up
crying okay that's what marriage does to
its [ __ ] but and here's the thing like
I'm fine like I'm like I've resolved the
fact that like I'm probably just not to
end up dreaming about him for the rest
of my life right but now I expect him to
know what he's done in the dreams when
we have sex in real life I think that's
only fair
you're not even saying like the other
night we're having sex and I was like
yeah we're doing it you doing it baby
let's do it just I didn't know dreams
you know he's like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about and I'm like you know a
couple minutes I'm like okay you about
to do that move come on baby do that
movie them on my lap you know and he's
like what are you talking about and then
we finished and I'm like what is wrong
with you you're so selfish she's like
what do you mean I'm like I don't know
two nights ago
you had seven dicks okay you're holding
back on me all right
so marriage is hard as all I'm trying to
say it could be very difficult also I
I've noticed that like my interest in
porn has shifted
dad are you here tonight I hope so
no I don't know just like I was watching
a porn the other day and there was a
woman with a wedding band on and my
immediate thought was oh she's having
sex with her husband they're 11
relationship isn't that beautiful and
friends like no that's not what's
happening like maybe though right maybe
I was just like maybe I would be
interested to see like if there was a
relationship porn like if there was like
a whole other site that's just like
relationship poor you know slightly
different like the categories are just
like instead of like anal I'm squirting
or whatever it's like you know like
birthday BJ just falls a sad woman with
like a birthday candle like into the
bedroom or like um maybe like like the
kids are sleeping sex is just two people
[Laughter]
or maybe it's just like that that final
like big category of like you know 30
year anniversary sex and it's just like
really sad music playing a
black-and-white film just two people
sitting at an expensive restaurant like
slowly cutting their food looking off
into the distance and just thinking
about all the regrets in life there's no
sex in that one it's just reality you
know uh I'm married I'm happily married
he's a wonderful man we decided to make
a baby real quick after we got after we
got married and I I really enjoyed being
pregnant it was an amazing time because
you just feel like you feel like a woman
you're nothing you have to get pregnant
to be a woman but like you feel woman
like the first thing that happened was
my boobs just go away bigger and I was
like a look at mama like just like I was
like going on bus like who wants to
motorboat real quick before they go away
okay let's do that just never felt like
then like I had this big belly oh my
goodness it was just why I was like I am
a woman you know I couldn't see what was
down I could not see my vagina
that is a burden taken off your
shoulders if there's ever been one okay
no I don't know if I needed to wax I
didn't know what I'm gonna stick coral
for all I cared I don't know what
happened down there like I just felt
like amazing you know and we found out
really early in what the gender of our
kid was gonna be because I was like I
don't want surprises from my vagina um
but we found out we were having a boy
which was like oh that's like a real
thing that's a big feeling I felt really
empowered when I found that out not
because boys are you know more powerful
or something but just because for the
first time in my entire life I had all
the parts dude I mean like that's a
beautiful feeling just uh I had my parts
my whole life and also not also I also
had a penis what I was part of the boys
club for the first time of my life
I was walking on the street just like
interrupting ladies conversations giving
them advice they never asked for for
nine months I got paid 23% more for no
good reason
ah it felt good it felt good you know
it's like it's a it's a real thing
knowing like now he's here and knowing
that I'm raising a boy to a man in this
climate in this environment I want to
make sure that he respects women so much
I wanted to know that every person in
the world was made from a woman it was
from a woman's sacrifice that we all
came to be on this earth yes I want him
to know that I made him I made his brain
I made his heart I made that dick that
used to be mine okay
I gave that to your welcome I just want
to get so deep in his head that someday
someday when he's in a loving consensual
relationship and he's about to have sex
for the very first time he calls me
first to ask permission to use our dick
I think I'm an amazing mom you guys you
guys are an amazing crowd being the
person who kicked off this album saying
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you